well Kathleen Kathleen - real name
Kathleen's well your cuz your real names
like birth name's Kathleen no what is it
[Music]
ca t TI en CE that's where where's
that's where Kat touch I just but think
does your family call you Kat no no one
calls me Kat
only me yeah only work do they call you
that because the elzar a struggle
mmm ounce into l is difficult well
there's no L in my name glass right they
revised it yeah so it would Kathleen be
a struggle so they're like let's just
call you Kat teen yes probably
that's the etymology of the name
etymology of the name not exactly but
there's usually made up no it's VIN
means how do
oh it's a real name oh come on dude it's
a real name but I grew up with black
people they make names up yeah that's a
normal thing hundred percent i grow what
do you think his name is what do you
expect all you gotta ask curls
something don't matter dude I like
nothing better than nicknames though
like I call everyone like well you know
what what's my Schulz like you either
have a nickname at your last name your
last name is sticky then you go last
name yeah like not everyone's like oh
did you talk to Andrew nutshells even
touch alt or schultzy yeah something
like that
that's just way it goes it's like sports
same thing in the locker it's yeah no
one's like hey Frey hey Brendan yeah
easy dude we're in trouble
last name shop shop oh they called me
when I first got to campus did call me
Tony G because they thought I looked
like Tony Gonzalez mm X again okay
if fer the Long's call me Tony G yeah
kind of offensive whatever it was
offensive felt a little bit why not X
again I'm not lat but you look Mexican I
grew my hair out yeah not even that your
face looks Mexican really yeah the top
part you know I mean that's what it came
from Native Americans um yeah I guess
that's fair like as Tech's from North
America from Mexico is a Native American
and then the Spanish went there and then
they became Mexican
what are you white you're not full I'm
full white my mom's from Scotland don't
get whiter dude you are not straight
white you don't have some Spanish no
Romany hook up with War II or nothing
always that look like it says it like
these kids on Twitter they think that I
look like I even know what it was I said
you know who Wario is Kaiba I mean
warrior when I was a kid playing super
mario kart wario was like how will deal
with me Wario what how old are you 36 I
played the same mario kart wario wasn't
I'm thinking while Luigi yes Wario are
you in the purple eye with the mustache
yeah but they'll need a luigi version of
Wario so Wario's bad Mario oh yeah so if
you look up waluigi that's who you look
like i say i Lord yet since I'm tall and
skinny and I have holy who knows don't
you have to go oh my god a [ __ ] car -
and I don't look exactly like I thought
that was Wario say what I thought that
no that's why Luigi that does look like
that's what I was wrecked at is me but
you played him in what grown-up I played
him like you played with him
no I play as the character toad bro come
on what I'm saying you you were familiar
with him not that character I don't know
who the [ __ ] that character tour was
until people started telling I look like
it yeah I know eyes noses pink or like
hey you don't like it like I wouldn't
think you're full life yeah how'd we get
off of UV and Mexican boys for Mexicans
being Native Americans I don't know dude
was trying to figure life so here's the
thing you're you're not Jewish though no
everyone thought I was and I thought I
would have to lie about when I first got
to LA why ever I remember I was doing
this on this audition for Ian was going
great like yeah they start about talking
about Jewish stuff like yeah you're
Jewish right job was like no I'm not
like oh yeah we'll call you what will
you become really what was the show what
were you what was the show about I
forget what it was called man some
sports show on E uh-huh hey why did
something bright better I didn't happen
right at the time but they wanted Jews
for it uh I think they would they were
like oh we got one you know cool yeah
there's Edelman and shop actually play
with the ball you've been record this
whole time right - yeah we spell it body
it's no Bryan Callen is
not here oh yeah he's on set yeah sent
out the the the Wario signal while Luigi
dude I don't know well look at that look
at that it's the ears I looked at myself
when we were we were doing this sketch
and I looked at myself a little bit and
and I had like this weird mama I got it
I kind of look like a bat sometimes you
look like a bat yeah I can never notice
these things until the internet like
informed me like I never thought I had
big nose or big ears until like I never
knew you thought you know nose is normal
like I know no one's invite you and I
love cocaine party if you have a signal
of his face when I said that honker dude
wait a minute nose or ears you have
normal sized ears well they used to be
big and then throw up from fighting they
shrink no your ears have grown in the
middle parts yeah but they can't grow
anymore like your ears and nose or
anything that grows as you get older no
they don't yeah they do come on look at
all the old dude look it up bro
I thought the rest of you shrinks and
that's what's left no smaller my dad is
smaller than he used to be but his nose
and ears are on point huh my dad's got a
piece man I'm not going to see he's got
a piece beautiful nose strong yeah dad I
had a nose is dude you dig you thought
your nose you don't have a big nose dude
from the Uni there's a side bro but you
know it is yours you're so Mexi in your
face yeah you don't notice it because
you're Max's man sexy Mexican bro your
[ __ ] Mexi over here dude I don't know
if you got a note like look at mine
profile my profile should be on Bill
it's legit I think it's a good look at
it they say women are more more
attractive to guys with big noses
is that right look at her I'm pretty
sure is their chair that's two guys with
money I think now if you have money and
a big nose smell you gold diggers but in
all seriousness I can't believe that you
think that you got a piece and your ears
are
big either you have a face I have a lot
of things you have a lot of face a lot
of fit yeah you look like a baby do you
think yeah you know like babies don't
have any shape yeah it's like a lot
there yeah it's just all faith yeah like
I got all like condensed like here
almost like a pug and that's like a
little forehead no you know who looks
like a pug
you know Yanis Yanis me Chris oh yeah
yeah yeah Yanis all of you honest is
he's just here I know all of his faces
in the middle of his face yeah it's
always strange yeah it's like somebody
went like this to his face yeah like
your thoughts if you're a chicken that
happens uh-huh if it's a girl it's
tougher go yeah yeah I guess yeah it's
yeah it sucks yeah but he's a still good
looking kid this young okay yeah yeah oh
yeah that's all right there he looks
like the nice guy in the world
yeah it's like I made the best year on
New York you're just the nicest guy yeah
we just learned what that was
you're a hero we call it a gyro back
home so ridiculous why it's gyro
okay mr. [ __ ] LA internationals we
don't know we don't know about all the
foods and all the products what are they
New York so what the food truck yeah are
you sure like they did the peeling is a
New York thing are you positive
and then LA was like that [ __ ] seems
dope and then we took it over and then
like real then of course we have to go
all extra with it and then real chefs
were like in the back those trucks like
your cousins were out there in the
corner making hot dogs outside the club
Mexicans yeah uh no I thought how pretty
sure the agents were the first ones
doing hot dogs rolled up in I mean maybe
another type of dog but I don't know if
they are you right a hamster damn known
as New York City's again yeah there you
go New York City first ones to do it
what's up bro anyway anyway uh dude were
you in LA we're checking out the theater
for the special it's like the last time
that I sure yeah I'm sorry you forget
things we saw it once so I could decide
and then became one more time so we
could just make sure all the lighting
and everything else would be right and
how we want to shoot it and where the
camera angles would be and shooting in
April April 11 and 12 yeah and you've
sold out 77 shows yeah yeah yeah yeah
every time I get on the air like so I
don't know
another one I gotta let them know you do
you know I mean I'm proud of you Matt's
[ __ ] dope um that keV you announced
where you're gonna can't say just yet I
can't say just yet
some people kind of figured it out but
contractually I can't say well there's
only like you know it's not it's like
you're an athlete you sign with a shoe
company it's only like three yeah sign
with yeah it's not that tough to kind of
navigate through you have a good chance
of guessing yeah yeah yeah pretty good
shot
yeah how about this it's not Netflix
yeah yeah shocking shocking yeah and
then he take that acceleration that's
like all right well where else kid yet
exactly I can't say I can't say anything
when can you say I think in the next few
months but maybe even after we film it
I'm not exactly sure why but I'm but for
a second there might have been Netflix
right are we allowed to talk about this
with whatever you don't want no no you
talk about whatever yeah I thought you
were actually like last time we had
lunch they asked me to write your
painting well I was entertained
DeGeneres they asked me do the do the 30
minutes that 15 minute they shrunk it
down to 15 da da yeah I know and and a
bunch of funny comics did it and I was
thinking about doing it and then we got
this other offer and then we told them
about it and they didn't want call up
that bread so if you want call five that
bread and simple as that man huh put
your money where your mouth now what's
up you already ten billion in debt I
don't not a few million yeah a big deal
ten billion well it worked out for you
though done everything's cool things
been good yeah and things are good man
we're just chillin
how's Charlemagne doing Sharla's good is
he yeah Sharla's good he go to Miami for
the Super oh no no no boys man no he's a
cow is happy he's I'll climb down there
talk to somebody
I mean he probably is like a million
opportunities to do these things but
he's good he's just like a die-hard
Cowboys fan so it's just like
heartbreaking every year for him he's
all bummed out yeah did you guys like
his dad is like a huge cowboy babe I
mean here's a Khmer zhing story I think
his dad is a band from Cowboys games cuz
I brought a Taser and like tell you
somebody oh damn yeah I really fun yeah
I heard yeah and he thinks Dax is like
the
the answer no I can't I don't think
anybody knows what the answer is it's
not death and it's also not Jay Jones is
the owner yeah it's not that it's not
him
how hard is it I don't [ __ ] know what
we're gonna say that's bro science this
uh yeah like how hard is it to pick the
team there's only a handful of guys it's
pretty [ __ ] easy
just got really just all the way yeah
it's like I think it's and maybe this is
[ __ ] up but I really think it's all
coaching remember when I came on here
we're talking about the wide receivers
are useless yeah theory that now is
pretty common
what do you mean comments a common
theory now everybody will agrees it's
useless why we see really useless and
don't pay him dime-a-dozen
no get them anywhere I could get a
bouncer from one oak and to make him a
wide receiver and then win a so a
guarantee that's so insulting
you think aim what he said this last
night I know you don't remember more
than I remember like a [ __ ] goldfish
[ __ ] but your point doesn't stand up
because why not he had the best group of
receivers and they won the Super Ball
name more than one they had Watkins
right no yeah they have Sammy Watkins oh
yeah they had a Travis Kelce you know
he's a tight end that's different he's a
receiver basic no he's a block he's our
seem tight at blocks listen they had
Tyree killed all there is you know
Holmes cuz he kicked the girlfriend in
the hotel that's the only reason you
know oh he's not the one that kicked the
girlfriend they both kicked no no no
Kareem Kareem hunt beat up his
girlfriend I think and then Tyreke just
kicked one Oh Tyreke just broke his sons
are say what he broke his son's arm well
how remember that but how I don't know
she could I think it was something with
a girl too that's how I know football
players did you beat a girl I won't know
you yeah that's fair you know or if
you're like a mass murderer you're like
an Aaron Hernandez thing did you see
that the doc yeah you know what you
think here's my problem think he's gay
no I think I don't think he was gay and
now all of a sudden can't defend himself
because you never come now
[ __ ] bro that's the best troll
what is this release Tyreke he'll and
his fiancee discussing his sons broken
arms got him in big trouble
yeah but you don't want to break your
son's arm well he was like discipline
them is pretty [ __ ] yeah but you're
not snapping it in half to the grand
brakes is on you [ __ ] up dad so
there's a thing like how much can you
discipline your kid you have kids can't
do that so I don't know I don't hit my
kids do you spank him nope
I think it's great a lot to read a book
but they're not alone enough you know
I'm saying for parents read a book Oh
read a book it's well-documented there's
been so much research on by hitting kids
that's not they don't respond I don't
think just scared of you I don't think
you hit them after a certain age but you
know like what a dog shits on the rug
you gotta like put his face in the [ __ ]
to let him know that you don't do that
yeah right because they don't speak
English right sure so when the kids
don't speak English yet you have to like
find some way to say bad or good they
know from your intention they can feel
like the tone of your voice you think
100 by now okay I have to I mean Here I
am teaching at parent and I've had kids
at all now we'll see if my kid ends up
like your Hernandez but what is that
maybe that's a thing we'll see maybe
kids are a little bit more anxious now
maybe things are a little bit more
[ __ ] up because they don't know the
punishment to break in the rules your
experience are kind of soft these
different source off when you spank
kiddies didn't call the cops
wait what I mean kids call cops on the
parents all the time because they know
the cops can come the house that's
absurd yeah it's the America saw you
should be able to hit your kid to a
certain extent not have you ever seen a
parent hit a kid in like the like in the
market or something yeah it's so in the
subway all the time is it yeah I mean
I'll be honest if the kid is loud and
the mom does it part of me is like all
right you know hey thanks cosign there
you go like you can't you can't be too
supportive because that's her business
yeah but at the same time you can be
like we appreciate what you did we
appreciate how you made a choir how you
made the subway ride more pleasant I'll
try to listen this [ __ ] mariachi
brand in this kid is a failure but back
to inter Hernandez that documentary yeah
there's the prowl documentaries they get
done yeah everyone's like oh they spun
it the way they wanted
TV memories huh like even if his fiancee
was like he wasn't gay and he wasn't
that bad of a dude
yeah even brendan dassey's making a
murder he's all I'm not really that
stupid it's just that what they want to
do or did you watch chair the
cheerleading one no I didn't that one's
good and watch you clown on it that
one's good no this guy right here mark
loves cheerleading dude good Matt talk
good Matt talk bro you like did you
watch air hold on did you just use your
lingo well that if you watch cheer
that's not the number one guy forget his
name Jerry allergy was so positive he
didn't make the team but he would stink
selling just clap I don't understand
cheerleading can you explain why we have
it I don't know either and I'm really
what's the point like what are you
competing at why can't you just dance
why do you have to combine it yet serve
why do you have to why do you have to
smile more it's evolved into like Cirque
du Soleil like they do these pyramids
now yeah and you want a perfect score if
you mess up you get points docked yeah
in the goal of it right like the the the
whole point of perfection no but before
that like the whole point of
cheerleading was to root on the football
team right or the basketball team Yeah
right yeah okay so no basketball team no
football team why are you doing it
entertainment man but it snowed the Blue
Man Group but they're going let's go
whoo-hoo let's go oh they don't say
let's go now there's no Panther nope now
there's not that it's like a Diplo remix
and they're just [ __ ] you would have
put the [ __ ] headstone on that
pyramid the biggest Mexican had to go
off and do it the cheerleading no it's I
don't get away from this hey don't walk
away from this I want to something let
me ask you something here though hey
just pick a Jewish name you'll figure it
out in Hollywood no prison this is this
is obscene I had to my girl yeah why are
all wiring it why is your girl Mexican
oh yeah mmm
I think we're onto something friend did
morning raise why are all gay dudes
attracted to cheerleading and also
because they like also being flight
attendants I think that move is like if
you're gay you haven't done that okay
you're gay and most of cheerleading is
just dude that tell you got a what not
the messenger gay you didn't know about
cheerleading and you saw a bunch of
people just go ahead that's my [ __ ]
though I've only met one straight
cheerleader in my entire life he's a
comic Chappelle Lacey you know she Bella
no yes yeah black kid he was a
cheerleader for Louisville really like
legit cheerleader
did he hit it he apparently could hit it
but he can he's gonna just throwing
chicks up and he was like dude I have so
many chicks from it I'm like well you're
the only in the straight ballet dancer
like I just say everybody yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's smart it is smart it is really
smart you sneak your way into some [ __ ]
that's actually genius
it is smart yeah but then you got a you
know I mean this is a great question
would you rather [ __ ] every girl or like
tons of girls and have every guy think
you're gay or [ __ ] a few girls and have
every guy think you're straight how that
[ __ ] all the chicken have guys think of
them gay I don't give a really my
friends would know I'm not but what if
your friends do think you're gay and
they're a little bit concerned because
you're a big [ __ ] game I'm a big bear
you're a big [ __ ] game you know you
wanted it that's yours right dog I'm a
bear Darko would you pee but do you not
be a week I'd be a twink they're not why
not I big for a twink twinks are super
bro twinks are small you mean dude what
is if it
there's Queens and what there's otters
that's right no that's right they got a
label there's beer in there's twink yes
in the middle is it otter there's a bear
there's an honor there's probably a list
of this somewhere but there's all these
different names they have all these
animal names what's a wolf um what's
your body type let's see it what what
[ __ ] site is okay otter wolf lean
muscular semi hairy
any age Joe Manganiello That's not me
bear we know what that is cub husky
younger younger looking good no hey
what's a bull super built maybe wait
what is it maybe some hair the wrong
to be honest do you think you're alone
take your bowl I don't when you when you
think about yourself like how you
identify yeah
are you like a mobile no what do you
think about this list I'd a I'm between
a chub and I'm a chubby bald Shelby both
know what I am all right
no you're you're you're not a wolf what
is it you're not mix between an otter
and a wooly muscular semi hairy any age
but Joe Manganiello is [ __ ] math oh
no oh no he's ripped dude you're not a
wolf pup I'm a wolf pup yeah I'm a wolf
pup lean muscle and render young my own
arey I'm kind of here I got a hairy ass
very hairy yes and I've always wondered
how the gays feel about that is there
like gays they like you know like gods
are some guys that are into like bush
there's no [ __ ] here but like are there
gay guys are like Paula Cass here but a
hundred percent really I would assume
right they don't have their flavor man I
guess you'd you know not I have no issue
with it but that is disgust
Jim bunny sculpted under 50 a jock all
right but one is wrong hey here's a
question
is it wrong I don't even think it's
anything's wrong with being grossed out
by sex that you're not into no like you
should be almost because that's what
makes you the sex that sexuality you are
yeah like somebody's like if you're in
disgust me wait what some asian porn
disgusts me
like what like scat babes
oh yeah yeah you might be a guy in a
girl that's disgusting if it's a guy to
girl [ __ ] on each
oh yeah but that's nice about guy and
girl that's more about the [ __ ] I assume
or you looking at the guy and girl part
and be like oh no there's only two dude
[ __ ] yeah yeah I don't know man but
you're a wolf pup mm-hmm I'm uh what was
a a chubby bull chubby boy chubby chubby
bull I love it thick bull
yeah yeah I guess I don't know I think
about that like bull you're a little
thick ball do you like bull yeah I think
boy I think like stocking like you just
think shredded oh no and I think like I
can you know like odd-job or some [ __ ]
Asians a key like stocky and like
muscular no I like that's a little bull
right right that's a pit bull you ready
you you're like you want like a bull
bull like a big old horns right like
they do that thing where they're hoof
pets the sand you know how they get all
sorts of cool names straight people
there's not like if there's something
well what do we name I don't think we
name girls right we just like oh Indian
girls hot fat lot lizard chubby lot
lizard what is a lot lizard a lot lizard
yeah like a girl Joe hangs around like
truck stops sucks off the boys after a
long road trip why are you saying this
in a tone that I should know it I mean
pretty I mean I mean around it in LA
it's pretty common toward Midwest you
travel enough yeah but one's never been
never heard it's someone called a lot
lizard no my uncle my grandpa were truck
drivers so really yeah
get out lot lizards man what were they
what were they shipping up here [ __ ]
on her owners and shows dude who knows
who knows you know what in New York
though yeah good there's nothing there's
no truck on the road enough yeah lot
lizard I love it a lot lizard so how
would you describe a lot lizard lot
lizard cardio bunny a lot lizard trash
see prostitute frequent truck stops hmm
seemed around like those coming goes no
pun intended you know gas stations yeah
a truck in life your truck in life is
ours ruff their podcast listeners though
I don't know they're on the road yet 12
hours oh yeah
just rough I always thought those cabs
were cool don't having one of those
anything you have in the back yes me too
it's like camping yeah yeah I've always
thought it's dope would you ever do tour
bus I've been thinking about that cuz
like Burt does one Tom's dumb one uh-huh
I don't guess you do one I don't do well
if I'm on the road too long oh you get
back to that family uh-huh I get
horrible horrible resentment for being
gone like my kid has for soccer game on
Saturday I'm doing stand-up in Columbus
so I missed a soccer game granted
they're basically wrangling cats and he
hasn't figured it out yet right but
still right I can coach better than
whatever dude was there oh you want to
be involved like that a little bit like
you he's [ __ ] up I know what will
work for him
yes him trying to experience it first
first time I went porn her firsts you
always hear people talk about that with
their kids like first I want to be this
first day of school first this first
that I don't know if I really remember
my parents at any of my firsts cuz they
weren't there
my parents were so involved all right he
had get bad yeah man yeah it works out
yeah right dude it really works out come
from freaking the gutter to make it dude
I know that's what they always say what
rate we get on it but when did comedy
get this [ __ ] reputation that like
you had to be molested or like beat up
or something of an alcohol problem or
drug thing
no how many funny people have you met in
your life that are just like funny yeah
how many of those people you met with
alcohol problems and you know depression
that aren't funny at all yeah they just
way more of those people than funny
people yeah yeah that's a good point
economy for a while though it was super
dark I think it was and I also think it
was like you know how like nerds are
trying to like carve out their version
of comedy now they're like well if you
don't do this it's not it's not funny
it's offensive whatever it is it's just
cuz they can't do it right so like if
you can't do something you just set the
parameters around what you can do Yeah
right it's it's like white guys know
yeah there's no dunk in the NBA yeah all
right I guess won't dunk exactly no
exactly you're just trying to set the
parameters yeah right and so maybe there
was a time where like comics were set in
there
ammeter is around comedy we're like you
had to have all this like [ __ ] up [ __ ]
going on in your life in order to be you
I mean like [ __ ] up [ __ ] is relative
you know like everyone has their
struggles like even if it's America like
we complain and [ __ ] about all the [ __ ]
in here it's like it's nothing compared
to the rest of the world like India it's
[ __ ] nothing no but that doesn't work
does it like I can watch all those sad
videos but from my point of view right
like while I'm dealing with at the time
is stress that's what I'm saying yeah
everything's relative your stress is
relative to your situation yes right so
here in America if you don't have a see
for a week you're freaking the [ __ ] how
could I live yeah and then people like
we've never had a see we don't even know
what anything is you're like oh that's
trauma to you exactly here we go so did
you grow up with a traumatic traumatic
childhood I'm like well my dad was there
my mom was there
hey there a divorce what you might have
had that one thing back on things in the
mirror every single [ __ ] knowing
you're Mexican your breasts your
family's not you right do you know how
hard that is especially growing up in
Colorado Colorado home rattle yes all
Ronald for the school shooting the big
one they call my well yeah yeah man I
was in ninth grade and our school shut
down big deal whoa Columbine so that's a
wrap a host that's like I don't know ten
miles from me well that was a hurry
we're like the the weirdos did they come
to school the next day with a little
like Pepin Nursing we're off the next
day cuz there was a threat on our school
like there was like so you know how the
losers went you know when this [ __ ]
happens they get on the internet and
they sent out a list of schools at our
next year on that list what a half
school like the next two days okay but
then when they came back was everybody
like polite to like the the weirdos was
they're gonna beat the [ __ ] out of them
they went right out I'm just kidding
shut up [ __ ] so no I just like even the
weirdos were like you know they might be
weird but they're like goddamn me that's
a little no one wore a trenchcoat do
that right now no we're out yeah trench
coat um been in a hot second yeah how is
that even useful a tire in Colorado
I feel like Colorado is like a winter
jacket yeah I mean it should've been a
dead giveaway we're in the [ __ ]
tragic oh man the black trench coat but
they did it for a reason they got from
some movie but I saw those [ __ ]
parents they gotta take a little bit of
responsibility kids in the basement
[ __ ] mapping out this [ __ ] thing
for you
mmm-hmm go down there and peep it out in
no month mm-hmm what are you doing man
yeah yeah I don't know I'm saying yeah I
know [ __ ] no one went down there there's
down there for six hours playing
grab-ass all night how much do we blame
parents that kids are coming up in
trench coats and [ __ ] mascara you
have an issue with this mr. [ __ ]
novotna varda if I can who said Dave
Navarro he was also in the band enough
you know say like some pants out take a
little responsibility yeah check in so
that's the thing like what is it when is
it a parent's fault how much can you
hold a parent responsible for with their
kid that's get that gets tricky if we
know it is their fault why can't we like
send them to jail for it the [ __ ] but is
it their fault if she's just negligee
like him just me like so I was working
what you want me to I was working him
his buddy were hanging out down there I
thought they're making robots yeah I
don't know look I'm not saying I have
the answers I'm just saying that there
is a situation where like we have no
problem blaming let's say if a girl's a
[ __ ] right what whose fault is it
no one's know whose fault is it no one
she's a good girl whose fault is it Chen
her dad thank you daddy issues or she
says a positive attitude listen his
experiment thing waiting to find the
right one did your elbow last week with
like the women's March or something
what's going on what do we over crack
them for you oh we're great they all
have a problem ho hateful
listen if you want to do it that's fine
because of guys are hos everyone's like
yeah get them good if girls like how
dare you but that's the thing if guys
are hos nobody's like where was it so
calm yeah I know right like did his mom
not go to basketball practice like
there's no recourse like if a guy shoots
up a school it's never the mom's fault
like anything happens to the daughter
right we have this weird thing where
it's like other dads should have been
another - oh you dad didn't love you dad
did whatever and then when the [ __ ]
Sun shoots up a school or does anything
when he's just a [ __ ] loser he's a
piece of [ __ ] on so then there's no
there's nothing it is interesting so
always complain yeah when the guy does
when the group warrants the death the
dad cuz that the shooters always in the
forums and like he's with these other
talks where's your marbles where's your
mom
well the mom can't be chatting like hey
honey your friends be nice today like
get in there
yeah given that chat room a bit okay but
here's the thing though the parents even
you know they're like well he wasn't
always like this he was spent on drugs
or there's the cigarettes like did you
watch watch don't [ __ ] with cats not yet
everybody's tell my girls into this
everybody's telling me about this thing
how do you not see this [ __ ] dude dude
I'm busy man me too but don't [ __ ] with
cats I don't care about cats you got you
get them then you along to another
company like it you can [ __ ] with cats
well he [ __ ] with all the case what
does he do he kills him yes they got
lives bro not these ones they got nine
[ __ ] lives not YZ one how do we know
that cuz these ones didn't get out of
the bag that yeah that's it put him in a
bag yeah and then and then like crushed
the bag he's terrible and then move on
they murdered a dude that gets a little
far yeah he took it to that gets another
level but like here's my point I didn't
kill the guy you got a why don't split
all for you yeah like sliced them up
anyways the point is even that mom with
the kids it slice them up feel anyway
good Matt I'm gonna borrow anyway but
even with that kid committing all those
murders we have we have Kate we have
videotape we had a whole chat yeah even
the mom was like I still don't think he
did it
oh that's another she defends some
amazing thing about women it down edges
they're the most down as [ __ ] and and
their love is so [ __ ] what is it
called
unwavering unwavering there's a word for
it what is it faithful your mother's
love is unconditional unconditional a
Father's love is conditional you think
yes hundred percent really hundred only
he's only loves you because you're
successful I think if I was cutting up
human beings my dad be like hey bro
chill it out yeah I agree
stop but mom's down mom is well what did
that person do what there
like if she doodoo my baby to piss him
off think about it and I looked at I
noticed this with jail shows right about
how amazing woman's love is if you're
watching on those jail shows i watch all
day okay you watch it girl 1 do you
watch a girl 1 yeah he's 60 days in 16
doesn't know the six days in isn't
enough I'm talking about like longer
term sure what do you got my point is
how often do you see their boyfriends or
husbands visit them never mmm cuz once
you come into crime you're single you're
single it's great it's conditional our
love right if you decide to murder
someone and go to jail you broke up with
me you made that decision right now
these girls not only will they stay with
their man while they're in jail for
murdering tons of people they'll need a
guy in jail sometime and stay faithful
it's unbelievable
unbelievable it's insane mind-boggling
we get into Hernandez Guerin son he
killed her sister's boyfriend and then
she sound over here was like well I
don't know what the [ __ ] [ __ ] he was
talking like why more women need to be
like that she's an example of women
she's an example of a ride-or-die strong
woman to 100 bullets and except dude hop
out from she got rid of the murder
weapon because he's like hey yo the
anything is over there of it and then
they got this [ __ ] on bit sluggish sit
lock it lock it lugging it - oh no it
was in the garbage that's a I don't know
is it you don't we put it I forget I
don't know some kid cats in there dude
so I'm telling you there is a different
type of love man yeah it's a different
type of commitment different type of
love and it's here's the other thing
you don't hear girls snitching on the
other girls either I feel like dudes are
quickness in it yo here's the thing
girls will snitch if your eyebrows are
fake if your eyelashes affect like if
you watch bachelor with your girl or
their hair is snitching no extension
like damn eyeliner here real you know
honestly one of the most fun things to
do with your girlfriend or your wife
sure I have a girl I do it yeah any girl
I know who's had tons of work done
fake tits are all that kind of [ __ ] I
love that [ __ ] I act like they're real
in front of my girl all theirs so I get
soap oh my god your girl's all-natural
all-natural yes the early wears makeup
she completely
Zach there's already that upset the
aggressors and pdz
enough animart real in the street
clothes I tell my girl I tell my girl
all the time I'm like yeah I think
Kylie's lips are fake like and my girl
will bring up [ __ ] images of her at
like 13 to now he did no it's so tight J
LeBron their sports yeah it really is so
yeah there there's a different type of
[ __ ] love but they I don't think
they'll snitch on us
I think they'll snitch on I think
they'll snitch on other women I do think
they will I don't think they have that
tally with other women their caddy bro
no your female comics that's true really
don't [ __ ] with each other like dude and
they front a we support each a son this
is the thing that we need to talk about
because they front they're like we need
to support women comedy and you're like
who you support we need to support women
comedy like all these girls talking
about we need to support women comedy
and you bring up a girl who's killing it
like Ali Wong and they're gonna talk
some [ __ ] where's this we need ammo [ __ ]
yeah mm oh [ __ ] we're dudes hardcore yes
well West Coast y'all got it yeah we
figured get them on board you know I
mean it's really just you know this guy
leaves you the skanks guys really wrong
with each other they support you know
commie and your pitous we're just
getting we just got to figure it out
because guys back home they don't know
the value of support you know I mean
it's like it's like you don't know
something to experience it like you
don't know they're like money won't make
you happy so you got money yep but you
would like if LeBron James tells me to
shoot the ball like this
I'm gonna start shooting the ball like
that cuz successful yeah but comics
doing this and he's killing on the road
a ticket yeah and I don't give a [ __ ]
them in New York and in Africa yeah la
guys I'm like damn all these boys are
selling the shows that all these boys
are crushing podcast yeah you know what
it is it's like mmm weird right
what it is is is when you have they have
like a there's like a famine mentality
out there cuz you can actually make
money doing comedy in New York like
spots yeah like that's that's why you
got money is all relative
everything's relative but like the west
coast
guys you guys all got risk because you
can't make no [ __ ] money out here
right like I remember once I did a spot
at the at the Hollywood improv great
Club and then she tried to make me sign
a w w whatever W nya for $7.50 she had
two quarters in the envelope yeah and I
was like oh no we're make money out here
like if you just shown the main room you
can I mean you know know what I mean
spot pay so like nap there was a time in
that leg when I would come here back in
the day and it was like you make ten
fifty seven fifty ten dollars for these
just little spots not headlining a show
doing 15 minutes yeah right now maybe
that money's going up it's different
yeah right but there was a time where it
didn't it didn't seem like you were
making enough money to sustain yourself
make a living figure out you know acting
or the other things podcasting right
like you guys wrote web series writing
like everybody here was doing something
else as well and you found out how to
make that other thing you know make you
guys millions of dollars so it's like
back home I think was crippling is that
comics in New York can make just enough
money to survive that's all they've got
the spots and I think inherently comics
are lazy I think the ones that aren't
end up doing really well but will do the
least amount of work to get the thing we
want you know and if you ask a lot of
comics like man I just want to make a
living at this and [ __ ] that's
all you'll do yeah if that's where you
said it you're there you won't go any
you might not even get there but you
will not go any further so the worst
thing about New York is often the best
thing right the best thing about New
York is there's all this stage time
there's all these guys are amazing the
worst thing is that you can get the
golden handcuffs you can get all this
states not in what you want to just
barely make a living now if you're just
barely making living do you have enough
to share or help no no because if you
take one spot from me it's problems it's
like well how am I gonna pay my rent so
now you're not really helping now you
really fighting for yours that makes
sense right where is where is I imagine
out here you know you know spots are
still competitive that kind of stuff but
guys are trying to
on the road drive guys are trying to
open for people etc yeah so what I try
to just get guys to realize is like the
comedy in New York is the gym it has to
be your gym that is not your end goal I
know there's a lot of guys in New York
like I mean I just want to get past in
the cellar and that's gonna be it it's
like I was just talking about L last
week and I was like that's the problem
the mentalities people just go I want to
be in the cellar and then that's it and
it's like he goes no no this is the gym
this is where you work out you make your
living on the road yep
you know but it's like the oh geez
understood that the older guys
understood but I think the younger guys
looked up to those og so much and they
kind of just and they like they had this
romantic view of what that would be like
so they stopped dreaming past that and
what I'm trying to get them to do is
like understand what gets you past that
because those old G's though that that
nobody's goal should be to just do spot
to the seller the goal should be you
just walk in and be a guy I'll do some
time yeah like my goal even even in the
city and there's a lot of great clubs in
the city there's New York Comedy Club
amazing the stand is really good and
obviously the seller really good look
really good place like Gotham right
Gotham's more than headliner club those
are like the headliner you're not doing
spots there nah nah maybe I'll pop in
I'll do like a comedy juice and stuff
like that but uh but there's a lot of
great stage time but what what I got to
get them to realize is this is a means
to an end like I never in my whole
career looked at the cellar as at the
end I was like oh I want to be here
because it's always sold out and I can
work out material more yeah it was there
for me to work out material even I
remember when I first got passed there
and it was like I was trying to joke
some people like what are you worried
about trying to you jokes I'm like well
what's the point I'll be in here like
yeah how would I know if they work yeah
like I'm gonna do my best best [ __ ] for
$25 yeah if we do the road you know I
mean you're making you want to try [ __ ]
on the road yeah let the fun I'll try to
whatever but I guess my point is you're
well now gars because you're you know
you're you but before if you were
younger let's say your headline your
first two or three years you're on the
road you start doing [ __ ] crowd work
for 30 minutes be like I'm not coming
this [ __ ] Robert yeah I guess it's
just [ __ ] that's it that's it sucks
coward
you know you should never do that guys
never do a hold on now
never do a whole stop now dog when you
first started headlining like you got to
bring your a materialman ya know you got
a kill absolutely you got a kill inlet
and if you're not good at you know crowd
work and don't do it if you're not good
at those types things don't don't do it
you got a murder but that was my
philosophy was it was just like hey I
want to make sure that you want to come
back next year
that's always what I'm thinking everyone
should be yet dude you gotta mark you
know let's take it this problem yeah
and it happens oh yeah you know some
[ __ ] have eggs and flows like I
get it like someone had like a big pop
because of something you know you could
do like the Correspondents Dinner or
some [ __ ] like that you know what I mean
in like everybody knows you and then
afterwards it's not as popular but
that's an ebb and flow is gonna be
natural in a career it's entertainment
yeah it's part of it but that's what
that's it's just getting people
understand there there are things that
you dream bigger you go bigger but I've
put up the guys in your like Sodor and
[ __ ] Normie like everyone have
they're doing it they're doing it they
are get it they still do you know you
talk to normally talk to soda that
there's they're like that
we shouldn't have to do social media but
we do it yeah it's one of those things
where it's just like yeah I'm sure
basketball players wish they didn't have
to you know jog what you do yeah it's a
new business yeah it's like it's like
with MMA and she's like I'm sure bad day
[ __ ] like I don't wanna learn
jujitsu yeah yeah they didn't have to
I'm a bar fighter I just want to go with
nothing on a dude yeah we go to the
ground I'm what is this ground [ __ ] like
I'm not good enough to be a boxer I just
want to go hook off on somebody Yeah
right
and then all the sudden you get two guys
come into that god I gotta learned you
just need to learn it and now it's a
whole different group of comics coming
up who started young I was talking about
this with Mark yesterday it's like now
that the internet exists comics are
starting young you got comics that are
24 years old been doing comedy for six
years yeah what yeah you know so and all
these comments coming up they're coming
up watching our [ __ ] so they're like
okay I got to know how to edit video I
gotta know how to you know add sometimes
I know how to clips I go to do all so
they're coming up and it's like if you
want to stay in the game you better know
how to compete yep
you know it's like LeBron learned how to
shoot threes you know cuz he had to
Jordan developed a fadeaway because he
had to yeah you know it's you're not
gonna stay in this game off of just your
name and people in New York
I like you URM what to keep out here I
mean there's some guys who got
grandfathered and rightfully so like
Chappell or some [ __ ] like that but
those days are kind of it can be tough
man unless you're on YouTube or it's a
new game through the social media it's a
new [ __ ] game and you know what
you should be excited because you
actually got some [ __ ] leverage now I
don't you don't have to suck dick at
these [ __ ] comedy festivals where
everybody's kissing up to the the
network execs yeah I'll go to jfl and
I'll go out to dinner
yeah dude I mean I'm not losing execs no
I don't hang out I'm like I'm doing Jim
Phil I take my guys me too that's what
they get my guys I do the show and then
I'm I'm if my boys are there I'll see
Tom Excel that's what I want to talk to
him out and even if I want to talk to
like like even I was talking to one of
guys jfl the other day guys rounds a jfl
the other day he was at the stand and I
was just like yo what do you look for
for new faces because I got friends of
mine who for some reason value that [ __ ]
which is there's no reason you should
value it but they do they think it's
gonna change what goes back in the day
it did like Kevin Hart had a natural set
in Montreal yeah [ __ ] you know everybody
got poppin absolutely now there's so
many today having it for Hannon on your
castles dope yeah yeah you're right yeah
it's just a different game now is it
that being said like YouTube is there
felt like [ __ ] know about you
already
yeah I don't got to go to the show yeah
click a video watch it and anyone can
watch it not just the crowd at JFS oasis
changing bro it's like oh you know it is
it is just it's all changing dude I I
don't know how much longer agents are
gonna be around or managers that's legit
like let's be honest cuz they're just
but I love this book in your venue
yeah I like his TJ TJ mark Walter I love
you you're my gosh you're always gonna
be with me and iris so he doesn't get
nervous or that kind of [ __ ] I'm gonna
we'll see no no that's my girl Sadie
[ __ ] me like it fine it's in your hands
it's a matter of fact you're fired
no but uh but like what I've said to him
is this is like alright so you have
these promoters this is what a lot of
people don't understand about the game
once you get out of comedy clubs when
you're in economy clubs is easy agent
calls a comedy club comedy club puts a
show on you do the show
letting you start getting into theaters
right so the agent doesn't call the
theater I just had to learn about this
[ __ ] the agent calls a promoter it's how
I like live nation yeah yeah
Live Nation AEG any of these other so
agent calls a promoter the promoter
calls it theater the promoter puts on
the show right promoter pays me why do I
need my agent to do it yeah what I told
my agent was like you gotta be careful
because you don't realize it but you're
about to be boxed out it's just like
uber drivers like right now there's
people listen to this power guys driving
uber thinking they got a sweet the
second uber finds a way to drive that
car without you you are out of a job fam
I mean you got probably four or five
years well if you plan on living more
than four or five years even if you
might have not figured that [ __ ] out you
might figure it out okay so so the thing
with the agent so I told him I was like
you realize that they're slowly getting
rid of you like they do all the
promotion they have all the ticketing
they have everything I'm a union 10% you
can handle the acts that do the comedy
clubs but once you get to the acts for
theatres right
I could literally call up Live Nation
tomorrow or AG or any of these companies
tomorrow and just say hey yeah I'm ready
to go back on tour new hour yeah you
just booked all the things here's the
thing though you know you know some of
the links myself replaceable Live
Nation's some of those other ones yeah
though can I have friends who have go to
go oh you have a tour well we want you
only to perform at our venues yeah and
they go here's a flat rate we don't give
a [ __ ] how many tickets you sell you let
us promote it you do your thing on your
end but the weary view at rate thank you
what me with that and it's big bleh
money so I'm taking less are you a gator
agent like all the works done that's
what I told my agent my agent yeah this
was great and I love my agent brought it
to me he brought the deal to me and I
was like why what are you doing you got
to do this they wouldn't go direct to
you though they could I could go but
they obviously dicey though family they
offer me seven figures for one year of
touring right and then when you break it
up to the amount of shows and that kind
of stuff
you could see if it's worth at this that
the other but what I'm telling my agent
I'm like you know you could do this like
you got to do all this I don't
understand
no you're the only way your agent
shouldn't be fired they said let's say
they offered you three million to do
this my agent is you wetbacks like yo we
need five yeah no no my age that's what
you don't want to do yeah not my agent
turned a yeah like he deserves it he's a
piece in like he he does a lot of like
almost managerial stuff as well like
that's my partner I look at him as my
business player he that has to be part
of it
peep happens to be part of an agency
it's definitely get fired but yeah but
I'll take them yeah doing that's a
friend yeah that's right you know know
will be your sister yeah yeah but you'll
be my agent be my assistant but you see
where it's going right hi now with all
the podcasts everything is so niche we
have our following we have all that kind
of stuff it's like like you'll have an
agent handling your podcast stuff right
no no I don't even know what my agency
does every once a while calling Bell
back yo you know this show looks kind of
cool hot ones yeah yeah I don't want to
check out hot ones
no big all right we're gonna look into
that and then they do jack [ __ ] you
heard from them they do nothing comfort
you can't just call the [ __ ] show so
I eat the spicy chips okay I mean
they're based out of New York's an easy
one bro they don't do anything none of
these people do anything that's that's
what I realize about this whole business
nobody does anything it's all incoming
calls well yeah I don't think what's on
ruses sorry agent is really like
pitching [ __ ] he's just waiting missing
a possible 14 all right I'll talk hey
Tom looks like this they haven't figured
out the missions pretty possible yeah
you keep on doing it every single
[ __ ] time it is weird like you want
to ask the Mike theme Monday through
Friday the Rick in nine to five home I
go yeah you you email me an offer from
Cleveland or Dubrow but the rest of the
day
what would you say you do for bright
like what's going on the rest of the day
my agents hustling - my PA agent is
hustling the other ones jobless like
normal but mine but no that's what I got
yeah no I know
because he's that's my guy man like
and I'm a very loyal dude people who
like sacrifice I'm really ride or die
for me yeah so that's important to me
and if you have those guys you take care
of them yeah like we're gonna let him go
we're gonna let him go yeah I mean like
he's it's time bro are we gonna do it I
love them I love them who are you with
I'm with CA you see it do they do
anything like they're the same agency as
LeBron have you met LeBron
have you been on the podcast out of it
that's how they pitch you right baby
like we represent LeBron I'm like
alright get him on the podcast yeah
cutemon everything about that it's like
alright man
uh no sandy [ __ ] I would never depend on
them to do anything forth like that I
would I know you got your business they
don't get a cup of course they do
they're coming back but then I get a
book [ __ ] you know LeBron you buddy we
don't see money Fred they were smart
they would they would create that
synergy yeah and they were smart they
would service every single thing no Maya
day should be getting you ads they
should be getting you [ __ ]
cross-promotional [ __ ] what are they
doing what are they again you just
booked event just booked my toy so the
exact thing that anybody could do yeah
this is literally a phone call
ready hi Columbus funny bone hey
remember when I sold out the club
you want to do that again okay
see you next year 10% yeah save tempers
and it's not 10% yeah this other thing I
get taxed no not even taxes
it's 10% which brings you down to 90
right now what is that of 90 it's 12 and
a half yeah so if you get you know
saying if they get 10 dollars and you
make $90 yeah yeah but they're making
more than 10% of what you make you
serves and yeah it's it's a lot of [ __ ]
gonna change well a lot of [ __ ] gonna
change confuse us are we fire agents or
not dude
cuz you keep selling out firing but you
tell me how great yours is I'm turning
mine into a [ __ ] bullpup
I'm coming over later TJ no I think if
you got guys this what I think it can
evolve into I think they're like we just
all band together this is what I think
the real future will be is we all band
together and then or the groups like
Arnett I don't like a network but like
we calamara now but with no written
agreement have your group right so like
I mean part of that group I'm course of
course no no absolutely I'll be I'll do
anything for you guys but like I meant
like let's say there's like six of us
right and we're all hit in the same
clubs hitting the same theaters etc
right we could have one or two of our
agents represent all of us right and
book the same theater runs for everybody
yeah right and get the best rate because
it's like oh do you want it or not like
you gave to Lear this so ada Lee is
doing that so and shows he's gonna come
there yeah so salty you don't leave us
right but we need a lower because you
get all of us or and they go to the
competition right right yeah and then
now we're not fighting against each
other and letting all these [ __ ]
calls happen like I speak yo speak to
the [ __ ] venues and like the
promoters that cuz they don't want to
deal with agents no they hate him they
don't want to deal with it it's like the
one thing whatnot you don't want to take
it like well I don't want to call and
argue the Commission myself
what do you mean the Commission well I'm
saying I don't wanna argue the rate
myself or not yeah that's why I have
them you don't be dealing with the
numbers and all that [ __ ] do you this is
what you want to create no dealing with
oh this is the number Oh Papa you think
he's Mike yeah hey this is what it costs
by oh that's it
oh my back Kevin Hart it might be a
little tough son we went through tough
we went through tough back in the day
when when we're trying to hustle our
[ __ ] ass off for years ten years on
the road grinding well no you don't say
we because I yeah you just you did it
right yeah yeah I didn't do it right you
should have been doing hyenas in Fort
Worth yeah six on I didn't write but I
got I don't wanna be lumped in with we I
don't take on the same thing I like that
that's that's fine that's fine so it's
like I don't know I think I think that
you can do that I think you could call
them up I think it's I think it's a lot
more a lot easier than we think it
strengthen numbers I think so I mean
that's the whole thing
that's the whole thing with unions and
that kind of [ __ ] like people [ __ ] about
[ __ ] on unions you know make all the
sense in the world you know here's the
thing that I'll get when people [ __ ] on
unions because it's the exact equal and
opposite reaction to the billionaire
right the billionaire uses their their
paying power essentially they own the
business and they could pay all these
people whatever they want because if
they don't accept the job then they
won't have a job at all yeah they have
they own the market it's like if you own
the Walmart in some little town that's
the only spot of what Oceana do exactly
right so the only equal and opposite
reaction to the billionaire is if all
the people who work come together and
they go not we want this money yeah now
both of them are bad because the extreme
version of both of them are bad the
extreme version of the Union makes it so
that the business can't make any money
the stream version of business makes it
so the people can't make it another
middle girl so hopefully you negotiate
and then have a middle ground what I'm
saying is we should just make all the
goddamn money [ __ ] should fire our age
no what I'm saying is like let's get
let's get the leverage that we never had
like right now we're in a unique time in
history man comics ever had this
leverage like now we got the [ __ ]
leverage like you know badly I want to I
want to just not only do I want us to
all do that but like I got my got my
young bucks I want to put on the road
you know I mean I want to put mark on
the road I'm gonna I want to do put
marks ass on the road he's on the road
with me but that's a problem but but I
want to actually have him be if I
eventually on the road by himself well
that's it well that but that that that
game plan has been going on since the
[ __ ] 60s where does he open up for
you mm-hmm so he opened up for you
you're in front of thousands of people
yeah he do we like that guy mark and
then you haven't come back to same
market and then you build the audience
yeah I mean there's that what else would
you do you have him and two guys we
don't know headline know what what I
would do is and this is this has
happening back in the day but like let's
say I'm coming to a club for whatever
reason and I'm just coming to Friday
Saturday so I say hey a headline home
Thursday I just do that in San Jose so
there you go you already doing it you're
are you doing that right I mean we enjoy
theatres it's different it's different
it's different if we do it useful if we
do a club we're doing specifically
Reps wolf yeah yeah I also just love the
club like I'm a club comic I grew up in
New York man like I like talking in a
crowd like I like I just I like that
intimacy so but I think there's cool
ways where we could do this man like man
but also with your with your with your
YouTube channel all stuff you're doing
with that you can highlight mark and the
boys audience so before they get in
there mark jerked off in my bathtub I
let him stay in my apartment no I didn't
know that's where only fans that
comments only fans calm my Twitter's
jagoff this guy is he is like so [ __ ]
primal with his [ __ ] he's actually a
smart kid but you're a he's a gorilla
he's a [ __ ] gorilla how old are you
mark right he's 23 yeah only four why
are you lying
you get LA you start lying about your
[ __ ] name dude I just want letting
though a little thin starlit 23 24 we
could break oh [ __ ] so this guy I say
you could stay in my apartment while I'm
gone right I come back from my apartment
and there are there's gelatinous jizz
bubbles on my bathroom like it's one
thing to don't say you didn't do it more
nuts he jerked off in my bathtub and
didn't have the [ __ ] balls or the
respect so just put it down now he has
very small feet so maybe he missed it
but he didn't well he didn't just go
like this and grow on it yeah and just
get it go through the drain so we're
like fine he learned his lesson we
disrespected him everybody on the road
knows him should I go oh yeah you're the
guy that jerk-off insults his tub right
everybody knows he learns his lesson
right Alex you know Alex does all the
video stuff Yeah right
Ammar need a job on that team now as
well but Alex been [ __ ] killing it
you know let's try to copy Alec stuff
get down that yeah they sure everyone's
trying to copy Alex they should they not
gonna you're like you're like you know
Rogan is Jamie everyone tries copy Jamie
or Qin everyone's trying to copy Alex Oh
sick that's the set they try to throw
some [ __ ] his way I'm sure I can find
some
Alex just gave an office so so an editor
porn or some [ __ ] with these hoes on the
road so so al we just said we just got
this new studio back out you out you
gotta come check the studio back okay
I'm in New York and are you out of
[ __ ] town well not me have a rose
well make apple right you just got all
organized yeah but um so we just get
this new studio right multiple studios
for podcast there's a live performance
space we'll do some live shows projector
TV it's like fun watch games all [ __ ] in
a good spot yeah yeah yeah it's in uh
it's in Brooklyn it's dope man it's
[ __ ] so cool and so there's six
months to [ __ ] build it out right
like audio-visual teams like [ __ ]
paintings it was crazy what we did it
was just unreal and this is all you your
team uses us yeah yeah yeah and and and
Alex walks in right I mean we had this
is the first day we're about to record
the podcast we're about to report flare
into for the first time in the new
studio we walk in Alex walks in and Marc
is shut the [ __ ] up dude hey shut the
[ __ ] up okay
the you asked for this okay Marc is
sitting on the couch right and this is
the weird thing his shoes and socks were
off right [ __ ] yeah his shoes and socks
are off right he's from LA
are you from LA Marc he's from Florida
now it makes sense doesn't it make sense
okay that would be my saying good shoes
and socks are off right god that's gay
now al walks in doesn't think about it
right he goes he goes he goes okay
what's her well you don't even think
about you I got what's up mark okay I
got he got here early or something like
that he walks past he turns around and
he looks at the TV and Mark is
ferociously fixing the Apple TV remote
like ferociously get off in the new
studio this [ __ ] girl
cannot help himself but to mark
territory hey was he sleep my territory
was he sleeping they what was he's right
sleeping no that's the crazy thing
you already did you stay the night there
yes did you say the night yeah it all
lines up dude jerk-off in my [ __ ]
place
yeah man he got up early twenties
clearly these subway he's 23 off its 23
Jack it is 25 all right he's 29 years
old
this isn't old well now now it gets a
little creepy okay for 23 I celebrated
so no for real man it's just you know it
was it's just a tough thing you got to
do with mark just whacking off all over
the floor of the studio dude it's a
crazy world but that's it that's we
bring in the road yeah mark opens for me
on the road just him yeah just sometimes
I'll have a local guy yeah I like the
local guy yeah yeah usually can get
dicey though can it that's a thing we
could we could be like I feel like when
it's dicey it's fun
mm-hmm feel it's fun when I see ya I try
I bring an opener and a feature you
bring both yes but for the long really I
would just roll the dice I found it was
kind of fun
you fly him out oh yeah I never think
we'll see that's the thing is I already
evalso I'm flying two guys out I know we
were always thinking we just got to get
out five minutes know them folks on that
video we get out we had I'll do uh yeah
I'll do one joke we're in Tampa broke
camp improv we were gonna do it for the
we have video of it in the drop it in
series right it's on the drop so if
we're in a Tampa prop and we're like
he'll I'll just do a joke I'll give you
one of my old jokes hilarious right and
you just go up there do the joke will be
a quick little misdirection so I open it
up to open the show
no I bought him up we were in my set I
brought during my sets off but everybody
knows him like ours you know synonymous
with me so yeah you know I'm right
so it was like he goes up we stopped the
show he
right he goes up but he was not a fair
fight this is a joke and it's one of the
first jokes I ever wrote this is like 12
13 years ago right and the joke was I
like it when a girl talk is dirty a bit
I just hate it when they repeat the same
thing over and over again right like no
so that's the joke and I say I go I say
how I say I go listen I'm gonna set it
up so they know it's a joke right
because it's a harsh joke I'm gonna say
no it's a rock on tonight's overflow but
here's the thing okay so wait hold up
before you go on how long ago is this
this is six months ago I see you on
stage
it's about raving [ __ ] is it was like
oh oh wow it just got dark man you got
real dark so now goes on stage he comes
over me right and I go oh you gotta let
before I go out you got let me preface
it because if it's such a great
misdirection that they're gonna laugh no
matter what they're just gonna laugh at
the misdirect I'm not gonna care about
the rape right yeah but I don't explain
that to him I just go just let me
preface it yeah so he comes up and then
he goes and I go I go now I just wanna
any goes he owes it looks at me goes not
got this yo yo before I start you know
you know I hate I hate when girls
talking I just hate when they say the
same thing over and over again now
they're taking him serious in this
moment right because he's saying before
I resort
it's not a joke right and then he goes
you know like stop stop [ __ ] crowd is
horrified it's my favorite part right
else is there for a second
confident smile and he goes that's my
time y'all I would be like damn you
yeah it's pretty joke any others I need
to sweat man sometimes those openers are
funny like it just in Tampa is when for
you oh I just rent a car how quickly is
it a divorcee or Dave you don't remember
her name of her this was because because
I did Palm Beach Orlando and Tampa and I
rented a car I'd had no future nothing I
just have them into this drive around
all ya [ __ ] cities so hey so my youth
Tampa and it was there's no it's the
last stop on tour I'm tired I'm in the
back I'm waiting I'm waiting and the
manager comes up because a man so uh we
got this female open up free man and I
go ah dude it's kind of tough my crowd
so bro we sometimes the females not be
so good at like to just check out us
dude trust me she'll blow up for Delia
she's fantastic
so it takes two Leah you know dude do
you remember blah blah blah how oh is
she in all capitals you
horrible so I'm like ah ah dude so the
so then that she's the featured emcee
comes in he's this little little Jewish
guy goes what's up man he's like all
sweaty I'm like what's up dude he goes
nothing your features my acts man she
came here with a [ __ ] a boyfriend he
goes dude dude I'm a fan if he tries
doing some [ __ ] will you help me out
dude I'm like what is happening yeah and
I go uh I littered I'm like I don't dude
I'll just see you at the show so he goes
back there this girl walks in her man is
oh I don't know six-eight job dude
Jack I'm like what is happening here and
she's all oh my [ __ ] boyfriend your
MC my ex he's so annoying I'm like
alright see you guys out there
MC goes out eats all the dicks doesn't
do well brings out the feature bit he's
like real caddies like ID everybody give
her a [ __ ] Janeane she's been she's
alright Brit give it up for so the
audience is like half ass she goes out
crickets crickets and she goes oh you
know what she's no you know what [ __ ]
you guys
she was this is micro sold-out Congress
I've been doing comedy for 12 years
Brenda's been doing for five [ __ ]
weeks [ __ ] you guys I'm gonna get my
time beer bottle cool I had a girl girl
didn't hit her just onstage they start
booing her but this [ __ ] does hurt she
gets her time it oh she does her time
and then goes ends it goes [ __ ] y'all
puts the mic and I'm saying the back ed
what the [ __ ] she owes sorry bro just
walks off dude and then I walk out I
just go up the crowds chair and I should
go how about that [ __ ] crazy I can't
believe they threw a beer bottle oh yeah
[ __ ] done [ __ ] add a woman was it a
girl who threw it I don't know it had to
be I'm backstage I'm like well it's
[ __ ] yeah it's the purge up you got
to go you have a piece of spit on your
balls distract the whole story I was
watch it was probably earlier doing lip
to bottom you
in the [ __ ] rhythm hydrated yeah I
know at one point is just connected both
you had like a little click spit breathe
all the stories you're on the coast or a
bottle of you when I'm dude
ah this poor girl I never understood
when opening access you know I came back
good but like you can't attack the crowd
someone else's crowd it's just bad it's
just bad business
yeah it's not your crowd it makes no
sense than anything you you are getting
you get to take advantage of that crowd
yeah I'm doing you a favor it is it is
an amazing opportunity like work on
material and like you get 20 minutes
right with zero expectations yeah how
could you come back hmm
it was fun though you got a good team a
good story Tampa's good temps get Sam is
a good city yeah we did Tampa cuz it's
like a theater it's built in the yeah
it's old-school it's okay it was an
Eyeborg is that you buddy boy yeah
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes not [ __ ]
with Tampa and chickens on the street
and [ __ ] and then there's Ben then
there's then there was times when the
openers were like dude like 20-year vets
and they've been they just they have
these 15-20 minutes that will set the
fire and they'll go out then I'll look
at the manager go how has he not left
Buffalo yeah how was he not headlining
yeah the [ __ ] Staples Center and he's
like yeah Oh papa
he's been doing that same 20 for the
last 18 years he's never do you ask me
to 21 he'll eat [ __ ] you only has those
pointy and that's it I'll never change
oh yeah and they're monsters you know
they're great guys yeah they're monsters
but they're dads and they might be
working at [ __ ] you know that
Starbucks oh [ __ ] but they've had this
20 that is [ __ ] fire do you tell so
interesting to you tell kids to move to
LA like you big guys who open for you on
the road I don't give anyone advice yeah
I'm in conference three weeks I don't
give anyone advice yeah interesting to
move to LA or New York I think you would
have to kind of do something to to get
going I wonder if you have to any I do
because I think you need to see what
your deal what kind of animals you're
dealing with got you
if I'm just an order and oh yeah like
floor is a bad comedy as well right
sorry
yeah but they're not great so if you're
the local club yeah you know Fuller's a
bad comedy spot he hasn't masturbated in
it isn't jacked off that's the only the
only place yeah but if you're just don't
land are you like damn I'm pretty funny
man you know but I mean can check online
but TC in person
you have come the comi story come the
improv of the factory or New York you're
like oh [ __ ] and you watch like guys
work on [ __ ] like daliyah's work on [ __ ]
now you watch that like well that's
about anything I got that I've been dry
five years yeah and he just wrote that
last night yeah so it's good you know it
I think it's good to see where you're at
in the pecking order
yeah I agree with that and the hustle I
agree with that you're not gonna see the
hustle you just can see the finished
product
well you see the house lot here it's eat
you know daliyah you know I keep using
clay but he's at the con store every
night yeah every night every night yeah
yeah I agree I agree with that I agree
with that part where it's like if you
want to see how funny you are and you
want to be motivated to get funnier you
go where the funny people are and
they're not in your hometown 100% and on
your hometown but also you can like you
you can pick their brain 100% yeah yeah
you can see with you but I don't
subscribe to the idea like you have to
go to New York or LA to get on
television to make it like I think that
you can I think that you can make it
locally you just have to have the
discipline to get better like I used to
say when I was on the road to any commas
I just get to New York the second you
have 15 minutes that works and it's fire
15 minutes you just moved to New York
and now I'm like hmm upload to YouTube
now not only uploads you to I'm like
what is your project like what are you
doing like what is your thing that
should already have been started before
you go what do you mean you're out early
like what is your show what is your deal
a podcast do you do some like straight
to the [ __ ] camera stuff on just like
a stand-ups I think yeah it's like when
you go to New York you're gonna be
working a full time job like you're
gonna be working way more than you are
doing stand-up like right now at home
you probably live with your parents or
you're living with a bunch of like
roommates and got you paying 200 hours a
month on rent like now you have you have
free time to like do stuff and create
content yeah if you're not doing that
here you're not gonna do that when you
go new true so I agree with you with
like the skill level if you want to if
you want to see what the elite guys are
doing and see where you have to go you
have to go to
they are but you're not gonna know
unless you see him yeah I just watched
Chappelle's special you just watched
Julie especially just like her special
yeah it's like oh yeah he's doing
stand-up thing then you got to see the
hustle man you got to see it because
you're not even doing remotely the right
moves
yeah there's just so much that you can
do so much you can do at home now as
well that's I guess what I'm trying to
say
it used to be though you can't still
need do it but yeah learn all that [ __ ]
that's what we always tell these comics
like to figure out what you want to do
learn all that [ __ ] like there's so much
you can do from home man there's so man
like you can connect with these guys for
home that's how I met mark we're in
Orlando when he drugs the rope yeah he
opened for us on the road and he just
reached out he started to help out with
clips and that kind of thing cool and
then he was funny and we were like yo
come on the road that's no but that's
that can happen that's like a very
feasible thing if you offer value 100
percent yeah I don't know I just figured
there's young comics listening to this
and maybe they could get some yeah keep
some curtilage in sure let me take a
piss before do damage get a piss no I'm
okay
I did a pee-pee I did a paper yes fellas
it is 2020 and you know what that means
a new year new me new fresh shaved balls
men listen up maybe some ladies some
ladies have some nut sack sometimes
hairy bushes our show 2019 if you're
going to pick any new year's resolution
this year let it be to take care of your
junky junk manscape is making it easy
with their grooming products all right
they're dropping their new lawn mower
2.0 what the skin safe technology so
this trimmer won't snag or Nick your
nuts and scaping accidents are finally a
thing of the past and don't use the same
trim you use on your face any cool man
Netscape has also the crop preserving an
anti chafing ball deodorant and
moisturizer you ready put your dirt on
your armpits why not put on your nuts
you 20% off free shipping with the code
fighter at manscape comm start the new
year off the right way by using the best
tools for the job your balls will thank
you get 20% off and free shipping with
the code fighter at manscape comm that's
20% off with the free shipping at
manscape commies code fighter listen
sometimes you got to start thinking
about
why am I not happy or maybe I want to be
happier there's something interfering
with their happiness or prevent you from
achieving your goals
huh there's something that told you back
from getting that job you wanted being
confident maybe try stand-up or maybe do
something you know maybe ask that girl
is there something why aren't you happy
the sun's out life is all good but
you're just not happy little cloud in
your life we'll get rid of that cloud
better help well assist your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist you can start
communicating in under 24 hours my
Christ's line it's not self-help I'm
talking professional counseling done
securely online all right
the service is available for clients
worldwide all you do is log on to your
account anytime you want send a message
to your counselor you get timely
thoughtful response plus you can
schedule weekly video sessions phone
sessions what do you want they're there
for you guys better help is committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so they make it easy and free to change
counselors if you need all right it's
more affordable than going to a
counselor in-person and financial aid is
also available better help want you to
start living a happier life today let's
be happy guys visit better help.com
slash kid that's better help and join
over 700,000 people taking charge of
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional
there's a special offer for the t f-- @k
listeners he attempts off your first
month at better help calm slash kids gen
yes bro dude first one okay so Taylor
Swift just came out with her documentary
on Netflix and there's a short clip
about the reason why she took a five
year hiatus and Nikki Glaser was
actually in there and it was talk she
was on a show talking about how she
thought Taylor Swift was too skinny did
it yeah it was exactly Liz oh it was in
a much older interview and she ended up
actually posting a photo wearing Tillis
whoops merch apologizing for it right oh
you don't want them Swifties after you
yeah but she got she got the cosign I
saw this my girl hit me up about this
and she basically just apologized and
said that whatever she said in that
interview was projection of what was
going on in her life she apologized
hallo
saw it and actually reached out to her
that's cool I like okey good you know
thank you
I do nothing great yeah yeah yeah she's
my cell - that's a nice little uh that's
a nice that's a nice cloud chase right
there well I appreciate so much one of
the major things that doc that we have
ability to change their pins over time
grow I'm so sorry to hear that you
struggle with some of the same things
I've seen and massive hug
hashtag none of my fans buy a ticket to
her show wow that's cool way to go did
you say there will be one person - she's
so goddamn powerful yeah I mean like if
you go out to Beyonce and the B I think
they're called the Beehive yeah
dude they'll shut your [ __ ] down yeah
yeah yeah watch your P's and Q's that
Beyonce yeah the the tail is so [ __ ]
maybe she was right maybe she was too
skinny I mean didn't tell us so she's
always been too skinny to me hold on
until Association she was battling
disorder so that she used to be a size
double zero and now she's a size six in
the documentary I'm just saying that
like the more she saw photos of herself
the more she realized that she didn't
like the way she looked so she just
slowly kind of stopped so Nikki Glaser's
right so she's skinny you looked at the
photos you agreed you change your life
what the nice apologizing for Nikki you
just saved your favorite singer Nikki
doesn't this white thing Nikki's bodied
up to that's why though
Nikki's a great job but here's a yeah
why are we upset about this like that's
weird some of fat shaming or skinny
shaming like if you're saying someone's
too skinny
this won't get you say some was too
skinny it's shame if you say someone's
too fat its shame yeah but both of them
are just pushing you towards the
direction of health
they're also observations right like
when once if someone thinks I've posted
patreon Oh some people for content but
the bag god damn you're fast [ __ ] shop
yeah you don't think my ass is on the
bike late afternoon like the motivated
no just [ __ ] motivated bro don't
think of [ __ ] but doing deliveries like
Mexican ass boy yeah
fashioned their bike you've roughing off
kotoba you've always been skinny huh
you just stay thin you gotta flip a
[ __ ] combo
national search like you did
professional bra not anything yeah do
you know marbs and red Sun I'm off that
I know right the bread I'm on that
refined sugars you spin anyway yeah Val
it then I'm at then I'm an otter dog you
went to Egypt right dude did you eat
carbs there I did dude the food sucks in
Egypt man yeah hey but I sold no [ __ ]
dude yo but yes [ __ ] like you but no
[ __ ]
no no you've been there for 6,000 years
you can figure out [ __ ] food nothing
that named something they've they've
invented there's nothing the pyramids
well that's how I know that he's an
alien
it's not aliens but it's not them it's
probably white dudes it might have been
white guys problem I've been like the
British Bulldog the mo buggers from one
day it was a gift
Real Talk no there's no way like
everything about that [ __ ] the pyramids
it just blew my [ __ ] mind
that's the most impressive thing I've
ever seen in my like I literally you're
the only person every person I let see
the parents like dude they're kind of
small was it [ __ ] there's a McDonald's
like outs out front when people have
[ __ ] on the pyramids almost everyone I
know that's guys there's like whoa what
are your other would say pyramids name
somebody Cowen for sure no way yeah I
was doing some operation other half yeah
who we take it out I've never heard
great things about the pyramids I've
always heard they're overrated huh
but you love them done they're the most
underrated thing I've ever seen in my
entire life they are the most marette it
questions your idea of reality it makes
you question reality you're watching it
and in live you we were questioning how
could this happen
like I don't even think about human
progress the same way after looking at
the parallel wow this is how I think the
pyramids happened I think there were
some humans they built the pyramids they
developed these cool you know to
technology that allowed them to do it
those humans died out and because we
didn't live in this like global society
where everybody knows what's going on
when you died snow did all your
technology oh yeah you can't tweet out
right so then another group of humans
thousands of years later the one that we
call the Egyptians now they pull up they
see some dope [ __ ] and they're like yo
last hours because you would claim
whatever is yours understand and then
every group that walked up on it just
claimed it the Greeks the Romans the
Jews anybody who
hold up when it was like yeah we made
that that was us that's our people but
there's no way in [ __ ] hell any
humans they're like no subscribe you the
alien but you know I think we just say
alien when we don't know how things
happen in our reality
and that's why I'm talking about
question reality like these [ __ ]
things the bricks themselves are so
massive there's no way in hell you could
move those bricks and you know that they
didn't get those bricks from that place
17 kilometers away that cross the river
with them yeah like there's all this
insane [ __ ] suspect this white suspect
you know what makes something a
civilization a group of people a
civilization writing write that is what
made the Egyptians of civilization
writing the hieroglyphics yeah so how do
you write about everything but how to
build that that's why they say aliens
though even if aliens did it they would
write the aliens did it and I know
someone's gonna point at a hieroglyph
where they're like an alien looking
thing no you go in detail about how
those [ __ ] aliens it you wanna do a
shot at theater would you want to detail
how you clean [ __ ] corn but you're
not go to detail how you build this
there's nothing here the idea that they
say that Jews built it absolutely
[ __ ] because if you look at the Old
Testament they go into detail about how
to build a temple everything the the
cloth has to hang two centimeters below
that there's such specific minor details
how to build a temperature not how to do
know writing whatsoever nobody else
replicates it and you know what you see
this [ __ ] in Mexico other parts of the
world it's stacked up raw Sun that's
what it is but at one point time was
perfectly flat oh they chipped away it
at over years using it to make weapons
etc this was perfectly straight if
there's a mock-up of what they're
supposed to look like back in the day so
these things we have on our dollar bills
too well because that's strange
now the Masons the people who basically
created America they were inspired by
the Egyptians and they think they're
like philosophy is that every once in a
while yeah this is what they thought
this is what they look like back in the
day perfectly flat white if you're
talking about the Luxor and that's what
it looked like how do you think they got
that idea when it's supposed to be white
there was blaim stone Sun it was perfect
white limestone that's what it's made
out of 6,000 years you get a little rust
should order no dude I'm telling you it
is you
not you cannot imagine it now it I'll
look at the pictures looks pretty sweet
without there's a little bit here's the
other odds where Isis is in North Africa
like a [ __ ] Isis is done bro now
we're dealing with [ __ ] coronavirus
from these two right like what the
that's the big issue right now why do
you have to put everything in the soup
that's you can't make soup without bats
guys that was a little bat let's be
honest when you see cuz I know neither
of your Chinese when you see the Chinese
do Chinese [ __ ] right like put a bat in
soup do you are you like oh we're now we
got a deal with this
Abbas Asians absolutely before
especially but yeah is that [ __ ]
annoying or Asian but that's annoying
yeah it's not you guys know right I know
what stressful it's like it's on you
take every time a terrorist thing
happens all the Muslims going a [ __ ] a
now we've got to deal with this at the
Diego China's like Asian Isis in a way
in a way there's a bat hand in the soup
like it's a [ __ ] Jacuzzi jacuzzi bath
he's just a suit like this yeah it's
great and you don't think it's gonna
cause some Corona but look at it Isaiah
was he legs and he looks a date yeah
look at that [ __ ] girl even of course
you're gonna get [ __ ] coronavirus
from this man you know you're the other
promise chin because it's you're great
so much traffic that's the other [ __ ]
the probably can't drive oh my god yes
dude in order the video that I posted
this was Bobby Lee's a guy literally
[ __ ] a chicken dude it was insane
like he's sticking his dick inside of
the chicken I don't even know checking
that [ __ ] blur freaks man yeah it's
just banging that fridge thank you
[ __ ] bad no it's not cool looking no
he's not he's a bat and he's in soup
that's not where bats are supposed to be
definitely not it's frightening but yeah
that's a thing
the other thing go last time you saw
something positive from the Chinese in
the American media do you guys got the
coronavirus popping right now and
they're eating [ __ ] bad
and hot tubs oh you're something like
posit they're saying this is a PR spin
well I'm just saying we never posted
anything positive on the Chinese what we
ought we get the phones from them that's
good your shirt to submit my sneakers
there's lots of positive things but
we're it's never in the media it's never
popping like Oh check out the [ __ ]
Chinese making all these thinkers on
Main and Cha it says it right on it do
you get Reeboks on well then maybe
they're made somewhere else guys this
might be by you cat you're the last
where's your virus no but it is a
[ __ ] it is a thing so you're saying
it's a complete PR spin so we have like
a negative view of China I'm just saying
whatever time it hits the news it's
always negative [ __ ] well that's the p+
out bro aren't they harvesting organs or
some [ __ ] listen I'm sure there's a lot
of nice Chinese people too bright a
bunch of land in Mexico are they buying
land in Mexico and you would be upset
about that because they're taking over
your country job is Mexican Brendon
ashab dude we have to talk about it how
do how do you non-chinese Asians view
the Chinese be honest now be honest
because I know I've been out there be
honest I think I think most people would
say if you've been around Chinese people
not there can I offer hot racist aprons
let's go this is good they call racism
and Asian procedures bro they know this
that's why I'm asking them because they
know the answer that I'm already they
know the answer the question that I'm
asking is trying to find a way to
Hollywood what ourselves around it was
listen so I might come off as a little
bit you know rude eating baddie rude
dude yeah that's okay so not not not
favorable Asians don't really love the
Chinese I don't know how much hatred
let's be honest here I will say for
Vietnamese people generally Vietnamese
people can't stand Chinese people thank
you so the what would the hey what's
that equivalent to in America huh
what's Buddha we can't stand on
if we know enough other countries to
care watching but the thing about being
Americans we do not give a [ __ ] like
everybody else's [ __ ] I don't think we
like or hate we're just like you're
there so that we can have the Olympics
every four years other than that oh but
I'm saying in America
yeah like like is there anyone who
America is like what would be we don't
have beef with anybody it's over it's
done it's you lost neck skins we love
Mexican Jews we love them everybody
flash its mega we own it everybody's
killing but as far as your country goes
opponent it we're not going with that
there's no like who we beefing with
realistically globally Russia are we Oh
[ __ ] Iran dude they did they [ __ ]
ran bro I mean that's no problem
I want no smoke bro they thought they
wanted smoke right
they knocked on the door of an embassy
we took out their number two that's what
happens did you see the [ __ ] would you
see the mean boys that's what happens
you know you definitely don't watch this
cartoon but Rick and Morty well there's
a cartoon I don't know any cartoon of a
quick if you ask lassie
do you reckon I don't know Rick know
this we didn't grow up cartoon it's the
funniest cartoon of all time when all
these [ __ ] Emmys yeah but they have a
thing where you don't see it the Ricky
boy where goes you son of a [ __ ] um and
we go that when we're about to go to war
with Iran
you said Germany's right now like you
said a [ __ ] um yeah he's always there
lesson before you son of a [ __ ] ride
with a tail sucking on the life up you
son of a [ __ ] I'm in this one yeah
that's what happens bro they [ __ ] with
the boys bro you can you want to get our
boys you want to get our frogs loose
wrong
yo that means that's Navy SEALs I
thought that was a new disease from
these [ __ ] of course no but do
the frogs could go all I'm saying wants
to release the frogs no I was I was on
hyenas talking about this but it drove
me crazy because that week you had all
these [ __ ] hipsters talking about
they're like geopolitical takes right
and there oh don't poke the bear don't
poke the bear we're the big we're the
[ __ ] we're the bear the otter the
bull the pup with a chubby bear bro
we should where does a chubby bear we're
chubby their children now we are a
chubby or a big old grin
yeah we're ready for the with me no no
no no nobody wants this smoke I'm just
saying you have Chinese effective hold
my [ __ ] back
here's that's the thing like people
think you think China could take us out
in a whip so many people and they have
nuclear weapons
here's the thing it would be problem no
we wouldn't want any problems with rust
because Russia is [ __ ] with Russia
the poundings china's guys out thinks
every Chinatown in America is a sleeper
cell from China that's fair I believe do
you believe that I'll believe that he
feels at any point of time they snap
their fingers and then all of a sudden
they start attacking us let's ask the
Asians thoughts the Chinese just got
some [ __ ] organized crime for sure
organized crime but that's not like
Direct Connect yeah to China try not so
many people there's so many more people
that'd be problems it would it be
prompted we would beat them but it it
would be K Texas takes out China alone
nobody else just Texas but absolute
Texas all against any other country in
the whole world and it's easy seven-game
series we sweep it 4-0 I'm not even a
question
hashtag America what does she go grab
your [ __ ] nuts
okay so did you guys see the Super Bowl
halftime show yes wait who's hotter
JLo Shakira it's Shakira by a million
[ __ ] miles dude away and close JLo is
wearing a [ __ ] maxi pad during her
entire performance did you see that the
wings were flapping out the sides of me
I couldn't even look at her ovaries you
look only one room for Shakira yeah
because you have to understand what's
going on okay I'm in a relationship all
right okay what I'm thinking I'm not fit
you guys are thinking about JLo you're
thinking about legacy you're thinking
about all these everything about busting
nuts doggy style no who do you think is
gonna make the nuts bus did you see
Shakira's hips telling the truth I'll
give you that
lips will tell the truth all that shake
boom pop pop pop pop so tiny bro that's
the thing like that camera oh yeah oh
yeah she went for it
she went for now here's the thing is
this it that's the thing yeah [ __ ]
wasn't good
you know who she was talking to [ __ ]
Isis broke I really thought was about to
be a terrorist attack at the Super Ball
is like yo she's signaling them oh he
this jail has on that thick makeup dude
look J Lo's tryna body dafuq a stun gun
she's biting too [ __ ] up I think Aaron
Rodriguez got her on some [ __ ] because
she wasn't like this before Aaron no
Aaron a rock a rod a chubby bull these
days he's shall eat Rodriguez Alex happy
in the face now yeah he might might be a
little chubby thing my point is this
Shakira for one [ __ ] one night of
[ __ ] look at the hip thing you're not
gonna experience that anywhere else
you're not gonna experience that
anywhere else you don't have any big
dudes
JLo has [ __ ] go through the list Ben
Affleck P Diddy [ __ ] everybody Drake
so great when you're bangin with Shakira
but when you're [ __ ] ago you're
thinking about like what guys she's
holstered oh yes
why cuz I'm gonna freak son so you're
banging it and you're like [ __ ] did he
was in here like that was crossed my
mind cuz me and it'd be like the same
cars
so if Diddy took that first I want to
take it for a spin
I see now that's weird see I don't want
to think about Diddy when I'm having sex
no I'll think about him I just go okay
the only time I think about Diddy when
I'm on sex is when I'm looking at a
grand I go take that take it take it
take that take that take that take that
the old ends look at Shakira dude the
way she moves her hips and it doesn't
work in the pictures in the pictures
you're gonna look at JLo but when you
look a location moves it hums it's about
the way she moves the head I agree it's
not even a question like you're talking
about a unique sexual experience with
that one girl on the left it is a truly
unique experience she though she's very
hips are moving like crazy
don't lie it's gonna be a different
thing your dick never experienced that
in your life JLo beautiful girl a
thousand of hers I mean you could get it
don't you
right person tonight I'm not gonna write
a ticket better than any other girl from
the Bronx I don't know
Oh Carta beats from the Bronx right you
think cardi can't take it down more than
JLo that's what I'm saying you know who
could give kardia run for our money
Shakira right there that Columbia mami
it's not it's and I kinda have a job
right now listen do you a little bit
she's going keep going okay if you got
any gifts or any movement of the hips
you would see what's going on you're
just gonna lay on your back you don't do
you lay on your back you give Shakira
the whole night with her on top you
don't even try to [ __ ] on top you lay on
your back and then she goes to work lazy
all night it's not about lazy it's about
you giving her that back you're right
dude but you gotta let her work I mean
oh it's just different
she's just tiny so look look just a
little amazing there's no meat on either
one of them they're super skinny no JLo
has a little bit of pop it here's the
other thing hey here's the other thing
what's the other name dude titties not
become cool anymore everybody
flat-chested these days that's true you
like some do you like some jugs I like
like huge [ __ ] job is really four years
old
you thought a big man I like like
[ __ ] Beth Chapman like Doug
bounty-hunter tits you know but such a
reverence dude but like titties aren't
cool anymore
what would you rather have would you
rather have I I personally don't need
tits like I want proportion body but I
don't want laps
I don't like flat chest I like some cake
oh I like some hips I like some cake and
then if you got a little titty that's
fine that's extra he's an extra little
titties extra titties like none yeah you
don't want to make like the fart sound
when you're on top of yeah no yeah yeah
I think there's this comic named Daniel
Simonson he's so [ __ ] funny this kid
he's from Norway but he performs at the
cellar and he has this great joke about
his chess is concave
oh it's so funny man this kid is so good
anyway well shut that look look at them
back-to-back go back to that watch the
ass shake and you tell me who you want
look at JLo struggling hello struggle
JLo look at all 50 years right she look
like she's falling down here I'll give
you that good Shakira after looking that
tape that's not even question after
doing the the playback I mean look at
that oh my goodness right
oh yeah okay I'm on board alright what's
next was I'm with either go ahead get
this one so yesterday a video was posted
with gez kissing up on Meg the stallion
and everyone is super upset why is like
because I think I don't know if it's
because I'm white but also his
girlfriend [ __ ] the mother [ __ ] the the
suit Erin JLo Meg bill if you look at
meg the stallion you like that that's
what you like doing for that you would
seem yeah she's so fine bro really oh my
god you're in today she Bronx Houston
Texas that's why she's done really yeah
you're really into it
oh I love it interesting yeah I love it
so does the video it's not your style is
it I think she's I think she's like
dance is really cool and I like her
personality and that guy stuff but it's
not my ideal cuz she's like 6-2 or
something right what she's like close to
six feet tall what yeah oh [ __ ] oh geez
II begin I supposed oh how about that
whole z-disc though what happened you
hear the Halsey song now no oh I think
that's oh Jesus you're sweet or have a
nasty oh he's busted on get 4g easy dude
I mean that's a good although can't hold
you down great move all Jesus I don't
know what Halsey is Halsey the singer I
understand she's a singer but like I
don't understand the purpose of her she
would still beats I think she makes the
music like what is she's Gary like what
is it really good singer she's I think
she's bisexual supers
everyone's bisexual now right that's
just what you do if you're a girl and
you're famous is there any girl that's
straight can I can you point me to one
girl that's straight is that her on the
right right there yes sir
well that's a bad picture come on should
help me out here here well I - her dad's
black besides she was complaining online
about they have no shampoo for black
people in hotels I'm like this [ __ ] has
some nerve and then I found out her
dad's but oh she's mixed yeah I see
but she's by now this week is there any
straight girl there's just 100% straight
I don't know it's like so cool to be by
these days but does that exist I don't
know in the entertainment you guys
aren't Hollywood no more I don't think
it ever exists
everybody just not be more open about
Demi Lovato's gay yeah everybody's there
anybody that's just 100% straight that's
a girl
do they feel like they could be
comfortable being straight or is it
don't make news if entik won't make you
won't give me headlines if you're just
straight man dude but I celebrate Halsey
and whatever she wants to do you know
yeah I mean she's cool I guess I don't
know it's not using good night yeah she
makes some good tunes I like the helmets
brief the music is super depressing
though do you like you cat um every now
and then I guess that's a no that's a no
who you like more her that Chinese I'm
gonna go with Halsey it took you a
second okay she's a baddie though what
else get you how many more you want even
one more one more
um let's do this one then you on musk
has an EDM soundtrack okay but just be a
billionaire we'll just shut your [ __ ]
mouth bro make electric cars and be a
billionaire dude
Elon dude make more flamethrowers so we
can buy and [ __ ] around here's a
question less music more flamethrowers
can we listen to the song let's just
here to a tiny bit of it now if the hot
track I'm gonna hate on exactly and you
got all the money to get the best
equipment the equipment also producers
etc did DJ Khalid and that's his vocals
on here too
okay give me a second
okay that's that euro [ __ ] is that
burning of him okay he's a little late
to the game with this but don't doubt
your vibe
now he's somehow hacking us with this or
like absorbs comfortable looking at I
don't feel convinced to do now but but
get us to the moon
[ __ ] your hotline stop it with this moon
[ __ ] bro you don't wanna go the moon
there's nothing there we know there's
nothing there what about Mars no why are
we spend all this money to go to places
where we know nothing is there we took
pictures of it it's like going Arizona
right it's like we know it's just gonna
be desert what are we doing here that
have no idea it's it's a stupid goal but
I think they're just using it to get
crazy money from the Gov so you could
fund all his other ships you see that
Chinese billionaires trying to fly some
date with them to the [ __ ] moon no
like a robot or something I know he's
trying to get a date to go them to the
Mars or some [ __ ] I think it's the
Japanese dude who invented the program
oh that's right and he's not I say
Chinese yeah damn son those days damn
saying that's [ __ ] up bro it's [ __ ]
up you should know better shot should
know better man Jesus said it I'm sorry
guys there's a serious one bar no fans
want to talk about those Yahtzee
Beyonce and jay-z not standing up for
the ho I saw that I didn't see it let me
see did it stand for the national anthem
yeah national anthem hey this might sing
you my district flag guess what else
yeah yeah that's one day me singing and
their families just sitting down what is
it is that but hold on hold on
so basically everyone else he's the he's
the connect yes to the the culture for
black people the NFL yeah he's the one
who's supposed to be the Kaepernick's
right-hand man he got cabinet the
workouts and all that [ __ ] mm-hm and
Kaepernick posted this I thought we were
past kneeling though yeah
so just reposted on his Instagram so now
Kaepernick is going at Beyonce and jay-z
so are we sure that they actually sat
during the anthem or did somebody take a
picture of them sitting and then put it
over the anthem to create some
conference that was possible and they're
not could they not stamp some weird
reason like Beyonce's dress or asses
blown up I don't know but I mean most
likely they were sitting during the
anthem so the reason why this is
the reason why this is stupid one is
because he said I thought were past
kneeling and two you know the cost of
that so every decision you make when
you're in public as a celebrity you are
aware of especially when you're an event
of this magnitude you know that you're
on camera so every decision you make is
calculated so if if it was
hypothetically if they did sit during
the national anthem they wanted people
to know they're sitting during the
transit they know understand you want it
now that's a PR move exactly so if you
want people to know then J I don't know
if you're in the right position to go to
get to go to Kaepernick now we're not
kneeling anymore my feeling really might
yeah my thing with cap it's like do
something dude but do something bro
right you're not out third you know he's
not out there giving any sort of nice
awareness he may he gave a lot of money
gave a million away like he's he's been
about it
cats been about it the tricky thing was
him trying to be in the league again
like that's when owner understand it's
like if this league disrespected you
this league did all this [ __ ] that helps
you out of it he did he's a he gave a
million oi know what you makes a year
from Nike Sonny give a million dollars
of his own money away like just cash
it's a lot of money bro hey [ __ ] for him
like in doing this this [ __ ] well the
aikikai contract yeah but he has a new
contract to them he's making more money
now than he was playing football see I
don't know if that's true you don't
think so I don't know I don't think he
is man I really don't I think that's why
he wants a play because at the end of
the day is like there's a love the game
there's also a lot of money comes in a
game I think he's more valuable not
playing I think he is more value to the
cause not playing but I think if he
makes it about him playing it distracts
from the issue which he's trying to
raise awareness for and then as far as
like the anthem thing is like my thing
is so little it's just such a little
thing like you don't have to join the
military in America you don't have to go
to basic training there's like literally
no cost to being American right like you
pay taxes if you make enough money but
you get to live in the best place in the
whole world
you get the most opportunity to do
whatever the [ __ ] you want be it an
entertainment sports or whatever the
whole world has to come here you do
interview outside of soccer to like make
money at whatever they want to do and
entertain on our sports or these types
of things that the whole you already
your grandfather into an ovule nothing
and then the cost is like
cool just stand up for the anthat late
yeah we're not even asking that but you
know you'll have to join the army like
in other countries where it's mandatory
service literally if if they made a rule
that was just like hey can you just
stand up for anthem artists don't
disrespect the the the flag that's all
you got to do a lot of people were
making the argument that it wasn't
disrespectful to the flag because cap
asked the the guy who's in the Navy was
like what were the Marine what was the
best way to go about this and the guy
was like wanted to take a knee because
the knee is like a sign of I'm
acknowledging it but I don't I'm trying
to raise awareness I'm not doing
everybody the whole thing is confusing
like if you want to boycott the police
then you do that at the police station
you don't do that at the NFL like it's
just you want a boycott brutality but
then you're gonna do it at the sport
that's the most brutal and what I said
there's so many thing is a conflation
there's so much [ __ ] it's also like
jay-z if you don't agree with their
agenda whatever then I feels don't be
part of it don't go to the game you're
the one [ __ ] doing all the [ __ ] for
it it's I don't even think it's real I
don't know who knows and and low-key and
not only do I not think it's real like I
think it's it's not you get you got to
know [ __ ] of standing up they
know they know I don't know if that's
real fast oceans I can't fathom it's
real because like there's no for that
yeah and he went out on a limb like when
he went said publicly were past and
kneeling when he said that public that
was a big statement he got a lot of
flack for he got a lot of flack for it
so I don't know I don't know I need some
more facts we should blow out her dress
or [ __ ] oh you like Beyonce I love
you yeah oh I like your music right like
the way she looks
what about the voice you like that voice
sure like to talk I'd like her to sing
to me yeah no not singing talking she
has a really deep voice when you into
that I'm into her you're into you I
could grow with a deep voice I'm into
Beyonce with a deep voice you'll put up
with the deep voice because put up with
it comes with me I'll put up with some
[ __ ] to be Beyonce sighs okay okay
she ate you Doug yeah thank you my
brother that's it man how I feel if we
drink over a while it's pretty long
two hours me all right dude be cool
Tindall yo damn dude damn bro are you a
need are
chirkoff font in real quick just let him
know where these fans in all this bro a
jackoff on the floor are you doing any
dates to your special uh yes what do you
mean by that me and I you do it like
well it's not the here of course you're
doing yeah yes a we're way every weekend
preparing yeah yeah wait yeah diandra
souls calm also we got a few tickets
left for the fourth show if anybody's
listening in LA the joint in LA yeah got
hope I'm in town
come to why would love line shows Oh
Easter weekend all right I don't know
when is Easter weekend you say it like
I'm super all eleventh and twelfth if
I'm here if I'm in town oh you're gonna
do a Hawaii this week I don't know if
this will be out by them but Hawaii this
weekend this be out by then this isn't
New York this is out today bro damn son
well oh ye a brother house II foods come
down to the show suits brother shoes bro
hey drive your Tacoma have you been down
there yet I've been to Hawaii and I've
been to Honolulu you performing coin
yeah yeah now it's my first time I just
went surfing I grew up surfing so I
can't win so why - sir
grew up surfing New York yeah so you
grew up boogie boarding no there's no
waves i surf dog item on the world
there's no oh really yeah have you
surfed in like Malibu to the big boys
[ __ ] yeah Beach in [ __ ]
yeah surfing at certain kawaii alright
that's a big boy yeah North Shore
what's up brother I didn't do North
Shore yeah we for that Brahmin off dude
that [ __ ] was not sure sighs [ __ ] yeah
yeah for real but now I always try to
serve wherever we wherever by the water
is the ice surf every day when I'd move
daily really yeah my big ass oh yeah I
love dude let's go serve on board and
[ __ ] haven't gone five for years though
it's kind of like golf you got to do it
yeah you just don't try surfing it's
such a beast so really funny sentence I
have my own board and [ __ ] I'm on board
you just taking people's boards we read
club you done with that bro you read one
yeah that's right I was embarrassed to
carry my born people like are you
paddleboarding like now [ __ ] you're a
big boy yeah it's a big board alright
dude go see Andrew enough [ __ ] a
Hawaii I'd love to go out there I'm just
I don't know it'd be fun
bring the fam I'm in San Antonio this
Thursday Friday Saturday
Valentine's Day weekend Ontario improv
that's for Valentine's Day
Vancouver jfl comedy festival one show
only we were doing 100 tickets left
I'm doing the VOC theater and they are
so nice we did that I'm excited for that
one nice then I close a February 2 coma
and then March theater on Chicago
Atlanta New Orleans Toronto Detroit
Minneapolis get your tickets TPACK AECOM
probably are you doing Chicago where the
weirdos the Bulls play not there good
for you dude thanks dude appreciate dude
thank you my man love and your shots
everybody this fun kid route